♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SAN FRANCISCO MAY
BE THE MOST WELCOMING CITY IN
AMERICA IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WITH THE
RECORD OF VIOLENT FELONIES, AND
IF YOU ARE GET THERE RIGHT AWAY.
WE ARE NOT EXAGGERATING
INCIDENTALLY.
HOW CRAZY IS THE     THE SAN FRA
HOW CRAZY IS THE     THE SAN FRC
HOW CRAZY IS THE     THE SAN FRS
HOW CRAZY IS THE     THE SAN FRO
SANCTUARY POLICY?
SO EXTREME THAT ONE OF ITS
ORIGINAL SUPPORTERS, ITS
ARCHITECTS, WANTS TO CHANGE THAT
POLICY HAVING SEEN IT IN ACTION.
TOMORROW VOTERS HAVE THE CHANCE
TO NOMINATE HER FOR MAYOR.
IT WILL BE AN INTERESTING TEST
NOT JUST FOR HER BUT FOR
SAN FRANCISCO IN THIS COUNTRY
FRANKLY.
I SHOULD STIPULATE FOR VIEWERS
YOU ARE A LIBERAL DEMOCRAT.
I DON'T THINK WE GROUND THEM
ANYTHING WHICH I THINK GIVES YOU
CREDIBILITY ON THE SUBJECT.
YOU ARE AGAINST THE SANCTUARY
POLICY AS IT IS NOW WORKING,
WHY?
>> I'M EXEMPT AGAINST ITB
>> I'M EXEMPT AGAINST ITC
>> I'M EXEMPT AGAINST ITU
>> I'M EXEMPT AGAINST ITE
>> I'M EXEMPT AGAINST ITI
>> I'M EXEMPT AGAINST ITT
WHEN I WROTE IT IN THE EARLY
'90s WE DID NOT INCLUDE
VIOLENT FELONIES AND THEY
AMENDED IT TO INCLUDE COVERING
VIOLENT FELONIES.
AS A MATTER OF FACT THERE IS A
THREE-PRONGED TEST THAT OF
VIOLENT FELON WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
CALL ICE.
SO I SAID TO THE SUPERVISOR WHO
DID IT, I'M NOT GOING TO AGREE
TO THAT BECAUSE THEY DID COME TO
ME AS THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR AND
ASK ME DO I AGREE WITH ADDING
VIOLENT FELONS AND I SAID OF
COURSE I DON'T AGREE WITH ADDING
VIOLENT FELONS.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
THE CONCEPT IS TO PROTECT
FAMILIES, NEVER TO PROTECT
VIOLENT FELONS.
IT SO WHEN I DID THIS ORDINANCE
A MONTH AGO, THERE WAS QUITE A
BIT OF HYSTERIA.
ALL OF THE SUPERVISORS AND THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY AND THE CITY
ATTORNEY AND THE D.A. GOT ON THE
ICONIC STEPS OF SAN FRANCISCO
CITY HALL AND CALLED ME ALL
SORTS OF NAMES AND SAID THIS WAS
OUTRAGEOUS THAT I WOULD BE
ATTACKING THE SANCTUARY LAW.
I'M NOT ATTACKING THE SANCTUARY
LAW.
I'M ATTACKING VIOLENT FELONS.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE PROTECTED
UNDER THE SANCTUARY LAW OR ANY
OTHER LAW IN SAN FRANCISCO
BECAUSE AS YOU SAID, WE
BECOME -- LET'S GO TO
SAN FRANCISCO, WE WILL BE SAFE.
THE OTHER NIGHT ON THE NEWS, IT
WAS VERY INTERESTING, TUCKER.
THE OTHER NIGHT ON THE NEWS ONE
OF THE PEOPLE MENTIONED THAT
THERE HADN'T BEEN ANYBODY IN THE
COUNTY JAILS IN OVER A YEAR AND
A HALF AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
STANDARD IS TOO HIGH.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NUTS.
JUST TELL US FOR THOSE OF US
THAT DON'T LIVE IN
SAN FRANCISCO, WHAT'S THE
THINKING BEHIND WANTING MORE
VIOLENT FELONS WHO ARE ILLEGAL
ALIENS IN YOUR CITY?
HOW DOES THAT IMPROVE THE LIFE
OF THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO?
>> TUCKER, I HAVE ASKED EVERY
SINGLE ELECTED OFFICIAL WHO CAME
OUT AGAINST ME IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION, BY THE WAY,
WHICH WAS PRETTY DRAMATIC.
I'VE ASKED THEM WHY DO YOU WANT
TO PROTECT VIOLENT FELONS, AND
THE ANSWER TO THAT, IF THE
ANSWER AT ALL, MOST OF THEM
DON'T ANSWER, BUT THE ANSWER
THAT SOME OF THEM GAVE ME WAS
THAT I'M CHIPPING AWAY AT THE
SANCTUARY LAW.
I SAID I'M NOT CHIPPING AWAY AT
THE SANCTUARY LAW.
I WROTE THE LAW ORIGINALLY.
IT WAS TO PROTECT FAMILIES.
I WE KNOW IF I WAS CHIPPING AWAY
AT THE LAW.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING, I'M RUNNING FOR MAYOR
AND I MEET HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
EVERY DAY.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THE
CITIZENS OF SAN FRANCISCO SAY TO
ME IS THANK GOD YOU ARE DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT DANGEROUS
FELONS.
IT'S THE FIRST THING THEY SAY.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK I'M
IN DANGER OF SWAYING A SINGLE
VOTE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHEN I SAY
GOD BLESS YOU FOR DOING THIS AND
B, I REALLY HOPE YOU PREVAIL.
IT'S THE MOST BEAUTIFUL CITY IN
AMERICA.
>> I'M VERY EXCITED.
WITH THAT TITLE AND SUMMARY FROM
THE CITY ATTORNEY.
INTERESTING THING ABOUT GETTING
TITLE IN SUMMARY FROM THE CITY
ATTORNEY IS THAT HE WAS STANDING
ON THE STEPS CONDEMNING ME.
A LITTLE BIT OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IF YOU GET THIS, I HOPE YOU'LL